نتابع مشاهدينا من ملف زياره الرئيس
الفرنسية مانويل ماكرون الى الصين يبدو ان
باريس باتت 9 علنا لتعزيز حضورها على
الساحه الدوليه فالى جانب تقديم نفسها
طرفا فاعلا في الملفات المختلفه وخاصه ان
الزياره تاتي في وقت تتصاعد فيه حده
الازمات بين فكين والغرب زياره ماكرون
بدات اليوم وستمتد لثلاثه ايام برفقه
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
تحت شعار الوحده الاوروبيه شرط اساسي
لبناء شراكه متوازنه مع الصين ويسحب
الرئيس الفرنسي ايضا
عشرات الخبراء الاقتصاديين والرؤساء
الشركات الفرنسيه بهدف دعوه الشركات
الصينيه لزياده استثماراتها في فرنسا ودول
الاتحاد ولفتح مجال الاستثمار في الصين في
مسائل الزياره راى مكروه انه يمكن لبيكين
ان تلعب دورا رئيسيا لايجاد طريق يؤدي الى
السلام في اوكرانيا مؤكدا ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا اثرت بشكل عميق على النظام
الدولي وانتهكت ميثاق الامم المتحده
الحرب التي قادتها روسيا في اوكرانيا بشكل
عميق على النظام الدولي الذي عرفناه منذ
عام
1945 هذه الحرب التي وصفتها مرارا وتكرارا
بانها امبرياليه واستعماريه انتهكت العديد
من مبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده والتي يجب
علينا الدفاع عنها بحزم لذا يمكن للصين
على وجه التحديد ان تلعب دورا رئيسيا